salut cireur soir vie qu on peut causer
fou
rubinstein arrête le chômage
tu me cherches tu pensé de chercher un
toit terminant à 5 min à feu doux son de
bijoux de l'écrin fort va y avoir feu
d'artifice je suis pas pressé pour te
faire une grosse tête
ces gars là tous les jours chez les mets
karine quiche aux lieux et de les gérer
un petit va dans ton genre c'était un
bergerac city il causait comme toi trop
depuis j'y porte des fleurs tous les on
l'a tous sont des chrysanthèmes dt 6 ha
qui m'impressionne pas si rennes est le
patron et ben ali comme ça si racj un
joker et on y cause en sont à 1 10 ils
sont car de brige m'ont fait des
tartines et la licence à
et si tu as dit fier course môme caramel
et si je faisais une marche ward
d'occasions si je te paye à un bon mot
d'un rocher en perse ira j'ai mon
lüscher
heureusement avant demain place à quoi
c'est tout on qui font dans un arbre et
césar dans le quartier tapis j'ai
annoncé un peu tôt que si tu avais de
dollars derichebourg d'accord sol se
réveille au sol mais voilà bien vrai
corniche au concert
tu veux jouer les gros bras l'epita rien
dans le sillage vers l'autre les prolos
et pour mon blast aurait pu dire
écouteurs je lui refile à vous faire
penser sur les naseaux et s'empare moon
c'était le champion alors sur l'armée du
salut par filer un cierge des enfants de
choeur ça aurait série et il y aura une
passe marée mais il ya toujours de quoi
cela et qui appréciera j'ai vu
l'amoureux safran tu parles d'une
géométrie stoppant génie laisse tomber
la souris ou c'est moi qui mène la voix
charmeuse maubert tu marches convient
dit qu'orange met en vrille au
frigidaire des leçons à la taille et
leur distribuer super y avoir droit sans
latrines raté bien avancer maintenant un
bouge pas si rare ou goethe accouchent
dans le muguet fleur de lin d'assumer
ton billet et poutant peut-on faire part
et d'une vraie carte postale règlements
locaux camp bourguignon ne saute un
monsieur sîrîn au bergerac steph de la
bande velpeau
8 avec la chine face à jean todt le fils
de ta mère en fait qu'en sierra j'étire
messieurs je te préviens je rejette avec
grâce on fait comme ça part tout seul
c'est trop de la progression du cac le
feu nos pères fouettards terry quoi un
indice à près de dix heures je travaille
toujours au silencieux qu'astérix où ça
nous arrive alors le séparant du cos
commandement sapin pour mon papa chez
l'état dans noces d'or filmé par deux
fondateurs sur la grosse irma voulons
non mon gros colon l'intestin grêle
étrangers venus de causer un mais je
tatoue fiducial
mais la femme envoie
oui